but that's just an illusion. Remember that scalar float
freely through tensor products, so there's really no sense
in which alpha and beta
are associated with the first qubit.
All we've really done
here is to use parentheses in accordance with the
multilinearity of tensor products.
Anyway, that's the form that we need to see what the measurement does, and we can see one
interesting thing right away
and that is that the probabilities of the four possible measurement outcomes are always uniform.
The probability to measure each
pair of measurement outcomes is one quarter, so, in particular,
there's no dependence
whatsoever on alpha and beta.
We can see that in each case by computing the Euclidean norm squared of
whatever vector is tensored to the standard basis
vector that we isolated,
and in each case we have a one quarter which we get by squaring one half times the absolute value squared of alpha
plus the absolute value
squared of beta, which is one, and so we get one quarter in each case.
It's quite important in
fact that the probabilities of these different outcomes don't depend in any way on the qubit that
Alice wants to transmit.
We couldn't have that an arbitrary state comes in up here and comes out down here and yet a measurement revealed
information about that state.
If you wanna gain information about an arbitrary quantum state, you're gonna have to disturb
that state in general.
Here's a table that describes not only the probabilities
of the different outcomes, but also the state of
the three Qubits together
conditioned on each possible
measurement outcome.
We get this by normalizing the vectors tensored to the different
standard basis states, but that's easy in this case,
we just eliminate the factor of one half to get a unit vector.
So, what we have immediately
after Alice measures is that Alice has two uniform
random bits and that's it.
In particular, she no longer
has the original state and she doesn't have any
information about it, she just has random bits.
Bob's state now does
depend on alpha and beta as well as on the measurement outcomes.
If we imagine momentarily
that Alice hasn't yet sent the measurement outcomes
so that Bob doesn't know what the measurement outcomes are,
then he wouldn't be able
to gain any information about alpha and beta
from measuring his qubit.
These four possibilities
that we have right here are sufficiently scrambled to ensure that no information
about alpha and beta
could ever be gained
through a measurement. That has to be true at an intuitive level because otherwise we'd have
faster than light communication.
Alice certainly can't
transmit information to Bob without sending anything at all, but of course Alice does
send the measurement outcomes
to Bob, so let's expand the table to see what happens when
Bob performs his operations.
In this column right here, we have the different operations that Bob effectively performs for each of the possible
outcomes of the measurements
like we observed before,
and if we go one by one and we apply that
operation to Bob's qubit, which is the first one, B,
we see that we get the same
outcome in all four cases and that outcome is the original state.
So, the original state of the qubit Q has been successfully teleported into B.
If Bob wants to rename his qubit and call it Q at this point, he's certainly welcome to do that, but the point is that now
he holds the original state
that Alice had and of course by necessity, Alice doesn't have it anymore.
Notice also that the e-bit
has effectively been burned up through this process,
teleportation has a cost
and the cost is one e-bit and two classical bits of communication, and when the protocol is
over, the e-bit is gone.
We've now established that
the teleportation protocol works correctly under the assumption that the top qubit is in a quantum state
of the form alpha times cat
zero plus beta times cat one.
But what happens if the
top qubit is entangled with some other system such as
one of our additional Qubits
as we have here on the screen? We might wish to use teleportation
under such circumstances.
Maybe Alice and Bob actually
plan to perform teleportation 100 times so that Alice can transmit
some 100 qubit quantum register
to Bob, one qubit at a time.
Or maybe these additional
Qubits aren't even in Alice's possession at all
and somebody else has them, maybe Alice doesn't even
know that they exist.
The question is, does
teleportation still work even though the qubit being teleported is entangled with another system?
Here, the state of the qubit Q together with the additional
system that we're considering is expressed as you can see right up here
where gamma zero and
gamma one are unit vectors representing quantum states
of this additional system.
We can always write an arbitrary state of the combined system in this way.
We don't actually even
need alpha and beta here, but if we include them,
then we can take gamma zero and gamma one to be unit vectors
and that'll make the
connection to the simpler case we've already considered more transparent.